you get to work with one heck of an
ensemble another movie I know it really
is just a bucket list
I really can't imagine because I would
be intimidated as I am to walk into
Christian Bale's room soon to meet any
of them so was there anybody on the cast
in particular that you are either super
nervous or maybe even just excited to
meet I mean obviously as you mentioned
Christian I mean he is like the nicest
guy class I mean you played Batman and
everything as well so that that's really
crazy and you know being able to work
with them the amount of dedication they
really bring into those roles I think is
really incredible because you know
obviously they do a lot of research and
they ask that ton of questions so I
think that's I think that's what makes
them so successful as well I mean plus
they're obvious they have a lot of
talent and everything but I mean the
amount of work they put in is just
fantastic and incredible so I'm still
trying to wrap my head around how this
whole production works here so you can
correct me if I'm wrong you get to shoot
with them while they're doing their
performance after it but then when you
go to set on location then somebody else
is standing in front yeah that's correct
so um yeah so the way it worked I kind
of stride it like a play in a way so I
went over I flew over to England in LA
to work with the primary cast um and
this was primarily capture their
performance as you said in the head cams
and everything so I would come back six
months later actually to working in
England and South Africa - and work with
different performance cabbage actors who
obviously played very different from a
Christian or a Kate or Benedict or
whoever and you know that's obviously
that's obviously very challenging
because you know you know obviously
after I remember how Christian or
whoever played it while playing it
playing across from someone who plays it
very differently and keeping my
performance organic I mean it's it's
challenging but you know I think it paid
off
so you're basically doing the whole
movie twice it's a kind of actually in a
way it does pay off I don't obviously
with them with the actual uh you know
with the actual stuff when I was
capturing my performance with the dirt
and everything in the long hair I mean
that was challenging because you know I
had to do a lot of physical and agility
training for that specifically so I
can't even imagine cuz while I was
watching and doing that I'm thinking
about my gym class for the whole the
spot position for 30 seconds and I want
to crumple yes so I did a lot of that
actually
I did some of that I did that jelly D
training and everything with you know
push-ups pull-ups stuff like that I did
a lot of physical training as well with
running on all fours you know wind
sprints stuff like that so that was
challenging I did I'm some research on
YouTube and also camped out with wolves
in upstate New York
did you realize yeah that was really
great that's so cool who'd you get to do
that with I run with my family I live
with my mom my dad and my younger sister
oh that's nice
and my my sister is actually a huge
animal over so she sees me wearing
animal lover I do I am yeah I mean she's
on a whole nother level though she she
you know she actually volunteers that I
am a shelter nearby yeah did Andy let
you try the performance capture at all
actually for him I think he was right in
the beginning in the process I believe
yeah I worked with Kay and she was one
of the first ones that I worked with and
you know obviously it is really
challenging to to do that kind of uh
with yah have you seen it yeah I'm sure
you've seen the movie yet but you know
with qog going around Mowgli and
everything it is really challenging so
I'd stuntmen like pick me up and twirl
me around and everything as cause tail
and I had the most the performance
capture stage actually on and that was
that was the first time I'd ever done
that I was super pumped cuz you know
Andy is the performance capture King so
I was really excited and no better
person to be working exactly him on
stuff like that so this is a super
intense movie I was telling you about a
particular moment that I'm not gonna
spoil that made me cry you pretty much
have this entire movie on your shoulders
and I would say every single thing is
pretty intense so what do you do either
in between takes or at the end of the
day to kind of know relax and smile and
hug yeah so the thing is actually in
between in between takes and scenes
I really don't really get out of the
headspace of Mowgli especially in those
really emotional scenes and really
intense scenes so I'm obviously I assume
I know that scene that you're talking
about but I mean that was a very sad
scene and you know I would stay in
character every time you know we'd be
cut or eat or reset or whatever um and
what's great and he sometimes just keeps
the camera rolling and just lets me go
almost and he really gives me that
freedom with with Mowgli while being
able to like guide me and push me
through the role I think it's everything
that an actor me
[Music]
you